traktor sternfahrt nach berlin
zehntausende bauern blockieren die
straßen der hauptstadt aus ärger über
die agrarpolitik
[Musik]
suche nach juwelen die ermittler
veröffentlichen aufnahmen des einbruchs
das fluchtauto ist identifiziert
schweres erdbeben in albanien die
regierung spricht von einer dramatischen
situation es gibt tote und viele
verletzte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann kein wunder
von mir mit buhrufen für die
ministerinnen und über 8.000 traktoren
haben die bauern in berlin ihrem frust
luft gemacht sie fordern mehr
wertschätzung für ihre branche und mehr
mitsprache bei den neuregelungen zum
tier und umweltschutz denn um das
insekten sterben zu stoppen wird der
einsatz von pflanzenschutzmitteln stark
eingeschränkt etwa durch ein verbot des
unkrautvernichter dass glyphosat und
durch ausgedehnte schutzgebiete um das
nitrat im grundwasser zu senken soll
weniger gülle auf die felder notwendig
finden dass umweltschützer existenz
bedrohen viele landwirte still
protestieren sie sonst mit grünen
kreuzen auf dem acker heute waren sie
laut hohmann leskovar manche bauern
waren schon am sonntag aufgebrochen
tausende traktoren aus dem gesamten
bundesgebiet kamen nach berlin
die innenstadt dicht der frust der
landwirte groß nitratbelastung im
trinkwasser insekten sterben pestizide
wenn über sie geredet werde ihre kritik
dann negativ das finden wir sehr unfair
dass wir mittlerweile die prügelknaben
der nation geworden sind und deshalb
sind wir hier hier vor deren antwort an
die politik denkt und sie gebar ordnung
man sagen wir ein bisschen
zurückschrauben
die stimmung aufgeheizt viele der
gekommenen sehen sich in ihrer existenz
bedroht immerhin die politik stellt sich
dem unmut zunächst die umweltministerin
die änderungen als notwendig ansieht wir
brauchen klare regeln auch das sage ich
ihnen hier ganz bewusst wir müssen uns
um die qualität unseres wasser kümmern
und wir müssen uns auch darum kümmern
dass es in zukunft noch insekten gibt
ihr abgang von buhrufen begleitet auch
die landwirtschaftsministerin stößt auf
vorbehalte
für den protest zeigt sie verständnis
mehr kompromissbereitschaft fordert sie
aber auch von den bauern
ich glaube wir müssen uns gemeinsam
erreichen dass wir landwirtschaft und
gesellschaft wieder stärker und näher
zusammenbringen wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann werden wir auch die
herausforderungen der zukunft überhaupt
nicht lösen können
für umweltverbände heißt dass schnelles
und konsequentes handeln
die maßnahmen für sie alternativlos wir
sehen es so dass wir eine änderung in
der landwirtschaft brauchen für mehr
umweltschutz für mehr klimaschutz
tierwohl und gleichzeitig weil das ist
ganz klar das geht nur mit den höfen mit
den bäuerinnen bauern müssen wir die
betriebe dabei unterstützen die
standpunkte liegen weiter auseinander
kommende woche immerhin gibt es die
nächste gesprächsrunde dann sind
bauernvertreter ins kanzleramt
eingeladen
im bundestag lieferten sich regierung
und opposition zu beginn der
haushaltswoche einen heftigen streit
über die frage ob die regierung künftig
wieder neue schulden machen soll
seit 2014 erreicht deutschland jahr für
jahr die schwarze null sprich einen
haushalt ohne neue schulden und 2020
soll es nach den plänen von
finanzminister scholz auch so bleiben
insgesamt plant der regierung ausgaben
von 362 milliarden euro klaus brodbeck
je öfter die regierung sich für einen
haushalt feiert mehr ohne neue schulden
auskommt desto härter wird daran die
kritik der opposition zu wenig würde
investiert die schwarze null ist
ökonomischer unsinn und verbaut die
zukunft unserer kinder und enkelkinder
die rufe nach mehr investitionen werden
immer lauter und zwar zu recht die frage
kurzarbeit die frage der ängste um
arbeitsplätze die frage des
wirtschaftswachstums die frage der
industrieproduktion die frage der
auftragseingänge hat nichts mit dem
haushalt nichts mit dem nächsten jahr zu
tun die regierung profitiert von
historisch einmaligen sondereffekten
sie unterschlägt erneut gewaltige
risiken sie wirtschaftet auf kosten
spätere generationen der finanzminister
hält dagegen diese haushaltsstelle die
weichen für das nächste jahrzehnt scholz
spricht gar von einer kehrtwende der
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik für mehr
klimaschutz
das ist eine menge geld die wir ausgeben
es ist eine substanzielle steigerung
gegenüber dem vorherigen haushalt es ist
eine substanzielle steigerung der
investitionen
es ist eine substanzielle reduzierung
der steuerlichen last von bürgerinnen
es ist eine verbesserung der sozialen
ausstattung es sind mehr investitionen
das klima rund 43 milliarden
investitionen sind geplant ein
rekordwert
es drohen umsetzungsprobleme durch zu
viel bürokratie und mangelnde
planungskapazitäten wenn ich unseren
haushalt angucke dann haben wir doch
kein finanzierungsproblem wir haben ein
umsetzungsproblem in unseren haushalten
das ist ihr einziges argument warum sie
nicht investieren dass sie sagen wir
schaffen das ja nicht umzusetzen das ist
keine antwort an europa das ist auch
keine antwort an die menschen in unserem
land bis freitag wird beraten morgen
geht es um den etat der kanzlerin
generaldebatte häufig fliegen da die
fetzen
zur krise in der automobilindustrie auch
audi hat einen massiven personalabbau
angekündigt bis 2025 will die vw tochter
in deutschland 9500 stellen streichen
allerdings sozialverträglich und ohne
betriebsbedingte kündigungen so ist es
mit dem betriebsrat vereinbart etwa 2000
neue jobs sollen im bereich
elektromobilität und digitalisierung
entstehen was macht der klimawandel mit
deutschland in einem bericht der
bundesregierung stehen dazu alarmierende
zahlen
demnach ist die temperatur hierzulande
seit 1881 um 1,5 grad gestiegen bis zu
4,7 grad könnten es am ende des
jahrhunderts werden
hitzetage über 30 grad gab es früher
maximal 10
im vergangenen jahr waren es mehr als 20
die extremen folgen mehr dürren weniger
grundwasser bei gleichzeitig immer
häufigeren starkregen und von neuen
krankheitserregern bis zur arbeitswelt
auf heute de können sie sehen in welchen
bereichen wir alle von der erderwärmung
betroffen sein werden
noch gibt es in dresden keine heiße spur
zu den juwelen dieben sie zu finden ist
nun aufgabe einer 20 köpfigen
sonderkommission mit dem namen
epauletten ahnt nach dieser
schulterklappe sie ist eines der vielen
gestohlenen stücke neben dieser schleife
besetzt mit als sechs mehr als 650
diamanten oder dieser kette aus fast 300
jahre alten perlen ihr wert kaum
einschätzbar
die gute nachricht heute brust stern und
degen sind anders als befürchtet noch da
stefan kech und michael b warum die
täter wussten genau was sie suchen und
wie sie rankommen und dass sie nur
wenige minuten bis zum eintreffen der
polizei haben würden eine hoch
professionell ausgeführte tat die nach
ansicht von experten insider wissen
voraussetzt anscheinend hat es doch
schwachpunkte gegeben und man wird sich
fragen woher wussten die täter vor
noch gibt es keine heiße spur aber in
einer tiefgarage einen weiteren tatort
hier brannte eine viertelstunde nach dem
raub das fluchtauto aus ebenso von den
tätern angezündet wie ein stromverteiler
belege dafür sind zum einen dass wir in
den vorzügen spuren vom tatort haben wir
noch einbruchswerkzeug gefunden
verteilerkasten ist ähnlich auch da hat
sich bestätigt dass der mutwillig
wissentlich in brand gesetzt wurde und
die folge war dass dadurch die
straßenbeleuchtung herausgefallen ist
was wiederum bedeutete und erklärt warum
die bilder der video wochen ebenso
schlechthin weil eben alle sind bereit
war
inzwischen wächst die angst dass die
geraubten schätze schwer beschädigt
werden könnten denn verkäuflich sind die
kunsthändlern bekannten unikate so nicht
man würde vermutlich auch wenn man es um
schleifen wurde unheimlich vom
materialverlust haben was es für total
zerstört werden also man kann nur daran
appellieren dass es nicht angetastet
wird
die polizei fahndet weiter nach den
tätern und setzt auch heute ihre
spurensicherung fort das grüne gewölbe
bleibt bis auf weiteres geschlossen
nach albanien eines der schwersten
erdbeben seit jahrzehnten hat das land
erschüttert mindestens 16 menschen
starben mehr als 600 wurden verletzt
heute morgen um kurz vor 4 riss das
beben der stärke 6,4 die menschen aus
dem schlaf
das zentrum lag rund 30 kilometer
nordwestlich der hauptstadt tirana
britta hilpert berichtet
er ist gerettet und außer lebensgefahr
denn sie können ihn noch rechtzeitig aus
dem schutt ziehen
in der kleinen ortschaft humane ist ein
fünfstöckiges wohnhaus eingestürzt ganze
familien sind verschüttet vermuten
konnte jede hilfe zu spät
das beben der stärke 6,4 bringen
zerstörung und leid in eines der ärmsten
länder europas
wir glauben in den trümmern sind noch
meine tante ihr mann und die kinder
zwei cousins sind schon ein krankenhaus
das sind schlecht gebaute häuser andere
erdbeben haben sie schon an geknackt
aber nicht wie heute
und dann gibt es wieder wie schon so
häufig heute
das beben heute morgen um 4 war das
schwerste seit mindestens 30 jahren und
nun erschüttert eine serie von nachbeben
dem ganzen balkan die hafenstadt durres
ist am stärksten betroffen
drei hotels stürzen hier ein und einige
wohnhäuser
auch hier können manche bewohner nur
noch tot aus den trümmern geborgen
werden es sind weiterhin menschen
verschüttet weiterhin werden auch
lebende gefunden
hunderte menschen sind verletzt und
werden versorgt
auch die häuser die noch stehen werden
heute nacht leer sein
denn die menschen fürchten die nachbeben
und sie bangen weiter um vermisste zur
not graben sie mit bloßen händen es
zählt jede minute um leben zu retten
kinder sollen in deutschland mehr rechte
bekommen das hatte sich die koalition
vorgenommen justizministerin lambrecht
hat jetzt einen entwurf für eine
änderung des grundgesetzes vorgelegt
danach sollen kinder gehört werden
müssen wenn es um staatliche
entscheidungen gibt diese konkret
betreffen
das muss aber noch mit den anderen
parteien abgestimmt werden um das
grundgesetz zu ändern ist eine
zwei-drittel-mehrheit in bundestag und
bundesrat nötig in münchen hat heute ein
prozess begonnen der einen
erschütternden blick auf die mangelnde
kontrolle in der häuslichen pflege wirft
vor gericht steht ein polnischer hilfs
kläger er soll sechs senioren mit
insulin umgebracht haben
aus habgier oder auch weil sie sich über
seine faulheit beschwerten
in seiner heimat war er als krimineller
bekannt petra neubauer und sarah ashley
ist ein schwerfälliger man selbst
diabetiker er wusste also um die wirkung
des insulins die vorwürfe gegen ihn
entsprechend massiv die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen 1 hat im märz
anklage erhoben und zwar wegen
sechsfachmord dreifachen mordversuch und
dreimal gefährlicher körperverletzung
hier in ottobrunn bei münchen kommt
letztlich alles ans licht im februar
2018 stirbt ein 87-jähriger den der
polnische hilfs pfleger betreut hatte
durch insulin
die ermittler nehmen georges wie ins
visier
in zwölf haushalten dann wenn es
probleme gab soll er den
pflegebedürftigen das insulin gespritzt
und sie bestohlen haben
die gew ist vorbestraft nach einem
pflege crashkurs wird er immer wieder
von verschiedenen vermittlungsagenturen
nach deutschland geschickt
der bruder von günther und herbert
neubauer wurde das vorletzte opfer des
angeklagten der fall jw für sie ein
skandal und ein fehler im system aus
meiner sicht ist der hauptgrund dahinter
dass das system der haushaltshilfe
pflegehilfe nicht weit es kontrolliert
wird und die agenturen oft aus
profitgier die leute nicht prüfen sehr
schwer hatte vor prozessbeginn eine
tötungsabsicht bestritten heute schweigt
er dazu sieht das gericht die vorwürfe
gegen ihn am ende als erwiesen an droht
ihm eine lebenslange haftstrafe
mit eindringlichen worten wandte sich
oleg senzer freute an das
europaparlament der ukrainische
filmemacher bekam dort den sacharow
preis für menschenrechte der ihm
eigentlich vor einem jahr verliehen
wurde
da saß er noch in einem russischen lager
in der arktis seine warnung russland und
präsident putin ist nicht zu trauen aus
straßburg anne gellinek
alex sense of ist frei nach fünf jahren
in russischen lagern
er fühlt sich sichtbar fremd im
plenarsaal von straßburg seine botschaft
ans europaparlament aber ist deutlich
und kompromisslos jedes mal wenn sie
darüber nachdenken über unsere köpfe
hinweg putin freundschaftlich die hand
auszustrecken
dann denken sie an jeden der 13.000
ukraine die im krieg mit russland
gestorben sind und an hunderte jungs die
noch immer in russischen gefängnissen
der ukrainische filmemacher sense of ist
auf der krim aufgewachsen als russlands
armee die halbinsel im frühjahr 2014
besetzt soll er anschläge auf russische
einrichtungen verübt haben
es entsteht sachschaden soft wird nach
russland verschleppt und dort vor
gericht gestellt
der vorwurf lautet terrorismus die
strafe 20 jahre
vier davon sitzt er in einem lager am
polarkreis ab ein hungerstreik bringt
ihn fast um
bei einem gefangenenaustausch zwischen
russland und der ukraine kommt es oft im
september frei nun also kann er seine
auszeichnung verspätet entgegennehmen
auch der diesjährige sacharow
preisträger kann nicht erscheinen der
uigure ilham tohti er sitzt in china
eine lange haftstrafe ab
wenn ich könnte würde ich ihm sagen dass
er nicht aufgeben und an das gute
glauben soll wunder können geschehen
alexov kämpft weiter ab jetzt will er
politischen gefangenen auf der ganzen
welt eine stimme verleihen
bei dir nochmal hin und fußball
champions league und zum bvb der steht
ja gewaltig unter druck morgen vor dem
spiel gegen fc barcelona im erfolgsfall
winkt der achtelfinal-einzug bei einer
niederlage dürfte es ganz eng werden für
den bereits angezählten trainer lucien
favre ein angestrengtes lächeln gegen
die krise lucien favre und seine
dortmunder reise nach barcelona
der bvb muss liefern favre muss liefern
ausgerechnet gegen die starken katalanen
wir müssen auch eine sehr sehr gute
leistung bringen sehr sehr gute leistung
viel leidenschaft leidenschaftlich
ausgepfiffen wurde fabres bvb von den
eigenen fans beim 3 3 gegen paderborn
eine deutliche reaktion fordert der
kapitän wir müssen einfach versuchen
übers ganze spiel hinweg mutig zu sein
mit vertrauen zu spielen und natürlich
müssen wir müssen wir auch leiden
abschlusstraining vor einer stunde in
kampen es wird ein erstes entscheidendes
spiel morgen für dortmund und für fahrer
schwere vorwürfe und schweres geschütz
der wada
die welt-anti-doping-agentur bezichtigt
russland weit reichender manipulation
und verfehlungen und empfiehlt
drastische sanktionen die auch
auswirkungen auf die fußball-em im
nächsten jahr haben könnten
das könnte für russische sportler bald
wie der realität werden neutrale staat
recht wenn überhaupt die
welt-anti-doping-agentur wada empfiehlt
wegen doping verstößen den ausschluss
von allen wettbewerben für vier jahre
es geht um dieses doping labor in moskau
in dem in der vergangenheit staatsdoping
betrieben wurde sowie um nicht
eingehaltene dokumentations-
verpflichtungen seitens der russischen
anti doping agentur usada nämlich messe
zu dem ergebnis es zeigt sich eine
methode in dem wahnsinn
sie haben dateien gelöscht es fehlen
also teile und dadurch sind gewisse
unterlagen nicht vollständig erhalten
die sanktionen betreffen auch die
ausrichtung von großereignissen somit
auch die für die euro qualifizierten
fußballer sowie den spielort sankt
petersburg entschieden über das strafmaß
wird am 9
dezember also in zwei wochen müssen wir
mehr
das wetter bringt neue regenwolken und
zwar schon heute nacht die details
gleich von osten terry marietta slomka
freut sich auf sie im heute-journal
viertel vor zehn wir danken für ihr
interesse wünschen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend und sind morgen
wieder da auf wiedersehen
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das tief über dem
vereinigten königreich wandert langsam
zur nordsee weiter
und dabei kommt regen auf ja und auch
der wind ist rechtkräftig zum abend in
morgen gibt es sogar stürmische böen im
westen schauen wir in die nacht und da
sehen sie schon den regen der allmählich
aufzieht ansonsten bildet sich nebel
und der kann auch ziemlich dicht seien
im osten funkeln die sterne und genauso
im süden die temperaturen dazu am
alpenrand leichter frost mit minus 1
grad und 10 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands morgen im tagesverlauf
ziehen weitere wolken durch und es
regnet es kann auch mal kräftiger sein
der wind frischt ebenfalls auf und ganz
im westen am abend dann stürmische böen
ganz im süden da kann durchaus die sonne
sich mal zeigen die temperaturen dazu
erreichten 6 grad im südosten
13 grad am niederrhein und 14 am
oberrhein
die nächsten tage gehen wechselhaft
weiter am donnerstag regen und viel wind
8 bis 13 grad am freitag möchten sich
schneeflocken dazu vor allem über den
mittelgebirgen und samstag wird es
deutlich kühler aber sonnig bei 1 bis 8
grad damit ein schöner abend